if you're watching the video version of
the podcast you probably see this tall
man to my left his name is Ryan Delk
he's from a company called Omni and well
we're talking about access today I
thought we don't do interviews but
occasional bring people on to help us
answer some questions I thought you were
the right guide to to answer some
questions here because you're the CEO o
of Omni which I've had I've been trying
to explain Omni to a few people and I've
had I've had a bit of a struggle okay
explaining it now so maybe you could
explain it to me
although the way you you tweeted about
this recently you said one way to think
about Omni is that we empower you to own
the things you want to own and access
everything else and it sounds to me like
Omni is a company that wants people to
have access to things that they may not
want to own what is what is Omni Abell
yeah so that's exactly how I think about
it so we think about Omni as empowering
people to access the things that they
want to own be that essentials be that
hobbies whatever it is to be able to own
those things and then go to access
everything else and so the idea is you
know we have we live in a world where
sometimes things are needed and because
of infrastructure and life decisions and
whatever people have just accumulated a
ton of this stuff right and so we think
of it about these items that you use
once a month or once a year or once
every five years and items that might
take up a ton of space in your home and
items that might also be valuable to
other people and so the whole goal of
Omni is to build a platform that allows
people to access these things when they
need it and not have to keep those items
around their house and so you get two
benefits one is instead of owning things
you can just pay for things by the day
or the month or the week when you need
them and then on the flipside you can
also free up room in your house and make
money on things by sharing them with
your neighbors your community sharing
with your friends for free and so we
think about it hopefully as sort of
building this future where everyone can
own way more but be able to own way less
but be able to do way more with things I
love it what so what like where you were
you all out right now with Omni yeah
like what cities where can people use
this service currently yes so we started
about the
years ago we're currently in the Bay
Area we cover most of the Bay Area and
then we're actually coming to Portland
partnering with the city of Portland to
bring Omni there later this summer and
so the story of Omni is a little
interesting we started knowing that in
order to build this sort of network
allowing people to share things we
needed to get really high quality goods
and so we started as a management
platform where you could add deposit
items that you owned so you could put
your drill your bike and you could get
it back whenever you need it so you
could free up space in your home but if
you still wanted to go bike riding on
the weekends you could have your road
bike delivered and so it wasn't storage
it was all itemized we took really nice
photos of it we would deliver it back to
you but that was really the foundation
so we spent two years building that to
build up sort of this network of items
that we could then unlock the value of
for the world you don't have the items
you can't lend right I can't go into my
house and zap a ladder and say all right
this out to someone else I'd be pretty
pissed now
Nicodemus was talking about this last
night we we were driving home from the
airport and I picked you up yeah and
you're like there's this ladder I use
maybe once every other month or someone
yeah I've got a ladder to get to my roof
and it's nice to go every once in a
while for sunset and like you know check
out the Hollywood sign yeah have a glass
of wine or something but it's like the
other 30 days during the month I don't
use it it'd be nice to make five or ten
bucks off of it and ladders are
interesting because they have a costs
not just to you an opportunity cost of
what you can make financially but it
takes up a ton of space yeah yeah so my
patio transporting it is you know it's
taking up room back there it's
transporting it is terrible and so you
know we think about the value that we
create not just in this sort of you know
money that you can make on items or
whatever but freeing up space in your
home and we think spaces should be for
living not for storing for storing so
yeah amen and the weird thing is we're
building houses that are larger than
ever and then two things happen one is
we just over time fill it with stuff
yeah you know I Mariah I built when I
built my first house in Dayton Ohio and
suburbs of Dayton I was you know it was
a huge monstrosity with full basement
two-and-a-half car garage which I don't
know how you put it a half car in there
I mean is it a prius or something like
you put three Priuses in there and and
of course you
most people are filling their garage of
of stuff so they they have a two and a
half car garage that barely fits one car
because of the ladder
all this other stuff the and so in a
weird way we start to lose access to the
things we even own because it's just
piling up there in the basement or the
closet or the Attic and how often do we
actually go and use those things so
we're paying for all this extra space
and we own these things yes meaning we
sort of hoard them but we we don't we
don't actually use the things totally
and it seems to me I've been waiting for
a business to come along and have this
model where you know you're sort of the
uber for stuff is the way that that I'm
sure it was pitched in some venture
capitalist meeting somewhere at some
point in time but that's the way that I
see it right I I look at that and I say
because growing up I didn't have to have
a basketball court in my back yards or
have access to play basketball and you
you didn't need access you don't have to
I mean people have swimming pools in
their backyards but I didn't have one I
mean we grew up or [ __ ] and I had access
to the YMCA swimming pool though and and
now it's like well how can we do that
with individual items whether it's
Ryan's ladder or I was on the website I
saw all kinds of things on there like
it's not in Los Angeles yet so yeah I
can't use it yeah but I'm really looking
forward to the day where I can get that
Chewbacca costume that idlers a day or
something you're just gonna do it like
to record one episode of our podcast
with video and just being a Chewbacca
outfit and not say a word about none of
us mentioned but there are other things
in there and even things like books I
got so much I'm glad well book on there
and you know it's like a dollar a day
and you're like well that's what
libraries do but maybe this and there's
something here if I'm getting a bunch of
other items and all by the way I always
wanted to read the tipping point all of
a sudden I can at the same time and and
the nice thing is you're taking you
you're freeing up space in one person's
life and then you are you're giving
access to that same stuff to too many
other people while I'm not using it
I was thinking recently and our friend
Rob Bell just did an episode about this
I've seen more and more of
geez now these little scooters yeah bird
and lime do they have them up in the Bay
Area they did they got rid of them I
don't ever meant just yeah set it down
but well they are they're amazing
but the problem is like people don't put
them back on the bike rack like they're
so they just end up thrown everywhere
all sidewalks that's sort of the beauty
of it that you are yeah I mean it's it's
great for us if if we don't if we don't
own that yard that all the birds are
thrown in yes I haven't seen any in a
yard yet but I've seen a lot especially
the just the last seven days like the
last week I've seen a ton of them but
both of them bird and in lime and people
are leaving them on like street corners
so it'll be on like yeah the corner of
Sweetzer and and Beverly or something
where that blue bottle coffee is and
you'll see one there and you see a lime
on the opposite corner and I'm
definitely gonna try it out this week
just you there's so much fun so so just
for our listeners this is a an electric
scooter that is its battery battery
charged you take a couple you know steps
or a couple pushes and like you hit the
button all set and you can go what's
crazy to me about this whole birdlime
thing is that there are kids there are
high school kids yeah like chargers yeah
making like hundreds of dollars a day
it's really I think yeah and going
around collecting these things and then
plug him in there was a um there was
this homeless dude that came out to me
in Santa Monica a couple weeks ago when
I was up there surfing and he was like
hey man you know can I get a couple
bucks and I was like yeah man sure like
it you know I gave him a little bit of
change whatever had my pocket and I was
like you know these birds I was like you
know you can charge these things and
like make a couple hundred bucks a day
if you you know if you max it out and he
was like like I blew his mind he's like
really and then you got a smartphone out
the charger yeah
you